we gotta we gotta end i was thinking we
gotta end every single
every single music with a bit we have to
end it with a sketch it's just
yeah like it has to and it doesn't have
to be an ad
all the time i mean but i mean the algae
because so funny
and it's like hilarious because it's so
big brained it's like okay well
they're getting the bag so that's just
funny
[Laughter]
you gotta get it in there somehow right
he's like
versus like stopping the whole video to
doing a [ __ ] read
i mean that would be funny too like we
gotta do it in the middle we gotta do it
in the middle next
time yeah bad [ __ ] hey guys i want to
talk to you about tide pods
don't eat them simple as that dude it's
just like it's shot like a mid-roll so
like it's like completely different
setup like it actually looks like an ad
we have like the skipped outside of the
[ __ ] desk yeah
the classic youtube read yeah hey guys
today we want to talk to you about
expressvpn
what the [ __ ] is this bro
has anyone offered to like pay you guys
to make a full song about
you know a product nah we kind of had
that idea
cody was saying like we should do that
[ __ ] like a while back but we we
we've kind of already done that on
cody's channel because cody
it was two brand deals right it was
amazon and then
yeah what was the second one was it
amazon again
oh no uh vincero watches vincero watches
yeah the song about being being late
being on time yeah yeah yeah
so yeah we kind of did that already and
i felt like the way we did that was like
as tasteful as you could get like with
just making like a full
up ad song because i actually feel like
if we had something crazy production
it would just look too [ __ ] chill and
everyone go i'll get this [ __ ] out of
here man this ain't tight
you know but i don't know no didn't we
have an idea where the whole thing
was like you know how every music video
now is like overly branded with like the
beats pill and the liquor and all that
stuff like if we
did a song that was specifically that
just as many
brand deals as possible oh yeah yeah
yeah as possible the video was like
so overly branded yeah yeah has that
been done
i don't think so dude maybe that's i
told my i told my videographer i was
like dude what if i was like silhouetted
in the back
not in focus rapping like a typical like
very just typical rap music video and
the product is just like right here and
i'm just like yeah yeah yeah yeah
wayne wayne's world kind of did that oh
yeah no way they had
yeah like they had like those ones where
they're like you know with the pizza box
and all that [ __ ] so
i feel like they kind of have that idea
nailed for sure oh we kind of did
everything before would it be it could
be hilarious
i mean it'd be hilarious if it was [ __ ]
that's not
rap themed at all like just random yeah
yeah
like drying racks and like orange juice
like clean action i'm trying to think
even more niche man like
like like uh [ __ ]
like weird weird like candles and you
know you know what i mean like scented
products and [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] lotion like stuff that is just
not
like hard to convey what about like and
like also like big business like
big like consultant and stuff like like
a law firm like yeah good tv show ad
yeah i was thinking i was thinking about
doing this and one of my next like long
long albums is like putting like a
full-blown ad
yeah for 30 seconds
just like a full full-blown ad i feel
like such a dick because i don't
remember this dude's name but there's
this comedian on his album
he's not like a like a like a massive
you know in terms of like
following he doesn't have a huge
following but dude i listened to his
album i was [ __ ]
crying it's like recorded live at a
venue
and he was like uh he was like all right
guys
now it's time for the ad read but it's
at a live show
he's like this this special is being
recorded
so it's got to make money somehow
and then people are like chuckling he's
like you know maybe if you guys actually
[ __ ]
paid for the tickets instead of me like
giving you all free tickets to be here
then i wouldn't have to do this [ __ ]
then he just does a [ __ ] ad read
during the show it's just brilliant he
reads it off a piece of paper and he
just folds it up he's like all right
so how do you guys feel about this like
it just picks up right
this is so good man so you should do it
is what i'm saying
yeah i mean i'm i'm sure like you know
if i got like a subway ad or something
yeah just like a full-blown subway ad in
my like
cody didn't you want to do that didn't
you say that we should just do a song
called add
or add read yeah and was just like
yo what if what if we joined together
like with like two other dudes
and started in sync but like
20 years later like straight money
making ad [ __ ]
like rev like straight profit revenue
like
sold our souls super hard the group is
just literally called
for profit that's a good idea this is
called for profit
dude holy [ __ ] no we should actually
make a boy band and do
boy band music like i'm like i'm totally
take their writers and producers like
make
cookie cutter pop music have us sing it
change our voices so that they're sick
and actually have like modern day boy
you know how pop punk is coming back
right now with like machine gun kelly
and [ __ ]
the jaden and [ __ ] like that we got to
do the same thing with like
classic boy band music yeah i was over
all
you know 30 like all the videos and i
was like dude
i gotta do this this is sick this is
their music videos were actually [ __ ]
wild
yeah they're so amazing brother on on
was such a good idea bye bye bye when
they use that rotating cube that's the
same [ __ ] they used in inception
yeah christopher nolan's getting ideas
from nsync
he can't act like he's [ __ ] this
creative genius instinct literally did
it first
dude i mean i'm i'm slightly down if you
guys want to start something like
i'm sure we could get like a ridiculous
bag right off rip
from a label like for like four problems
to start a boy band the [ __ ] 100
million percent
it's so [ __ ] funny dude the most meta
of medicine that's like the
it truly is we need no we need someone
who can harmonize their ass off dude we
need like the [ __ ] hell
like we need that guy we could get louis
grant you guys know lewis grant
um i'm not gonna pretend he's on a
couple of my records he's like he used
to live with y2k and he's a
super [ __ ] talented uh is it lewis
yeah who's okay okay yeah yeah yeah
um but i'd be like honestly
we spend like one month together just
banging out an album bang out like eight
videos and just like
set it up over a year like we might have
to cut this out of
the podcast because no no
no no we're not cutting it out we're not
cutting out people need to know what
dude in [ __ ] a year when we're
headlining coachella
as people need to be able to go back to
this to see the inception
i'm like conception i don't think i've
been more down to do something
i was like inspired as [ __ ] by nsync for
profit dawg can you imagine that [ __ ] at
the top of the [ __ ] coachella [ __ ]
it's like
for-profit beyonce post malone
and everybody's whole set is just like
us holding up
like flyers and tickets no bro we're
gonna have like right like race car
driver outfits like hella branded like
so many patches dude
and like like even like our stage towels
and [ __ ] it's like oh this is like
pirelli just
oh wipe this off wait it's it's four
it's for profit right like the number
four definitely oh we could get max
profit you have to go down before and is
it is profit
wait is profit spelled like like profit
no no
it's like it's like for money like for
profit
for profit yeah yeah yeah cause it could
also be four
profits you know what i'm saying like
yeah that's kind of deep
dude yeah big brain big brain
big brain moves
dog that would be so funny man in
between i'm just thinking even more like
in between a song like
guys so important to stay hydrated up
with red bull
anyway what were you about to say no i
like we have probably a year until shows
resume
in my opinion dude i yeah like i think
i'm kind of down to do it like what do
we gotta lose i almost feel like it's
more man
i'm starting to feel like it's it's
gonna be like 20 22 when like touring is
really back
it's really all dependent on the vaccine
and how fast it gets cleared
but like we don't know where that's at
hey we just we just need like whatever
opiate shake trump got
just put that [ __ ] in a muscle milk
[ __ ] jar sell it for 150
yeah honestly he was high as hell when
he got out of the
dude i was faded
did you see that feeling better than
i've ever felt in 20 years
what tweet i didn't see anything dude
well he tweeted he
didn't give him [ __ ] molly yeah he he
tweeted this [ __ ] where he was like you
know
i just got out of the hospital i feel
better than i did 20 years ago like some
crazy over-the-top [ __ ] but i was crying
because someone like
photoshopped this tweet of him is like
he's like i'm on morphine
everybody gets healthcare my bad
wait is it is that real no i can't be
real no no that one's not real
it's not me crying just thinking about
him on morphine just like
completely flipping his political
stances like he just suddenly
like left as [ __ ] he's like i'm giving
away all my money
vote biden yeah he's like yeah [ __ ] this
[ __ ] i'm out man i don't want to do this
anymore
you